[Music]
i thought he had rook 82 as well
yeah big blunder big blunder by eric
blunder
yeah picaro is i was i'm not even right
back in this
just winning oh man no it was there
right but hikaru is showing the
perseverance to hold on that bad
position and uh
now as long as he doesn't blunder the
rook on e1 he should
be getting the victory yeah bishop h6
very tricky move
is this mate though oh wait it was me
rookie three k3 oh my gosh what just
happened there
i was i was trying to follow the eval
bar it didn't even know what was going
on
super impressive because that is uh not
easy to do the road to the finals for
both of these guys
has been very very intense
and obviously beating hikaru probably
gave alireza the confidence that he
needed coming into this one
what a performance by the youngster and
queen d3 check just for good measure
check here so you take this
forward check that is extreme precision
he didn't have to but he did that's ali
and he wins the queen i mean the guy is
just on another level
yeah well welcome to the alley resident
show i mean
[Music]
i need my rook c6 he might try uh
wow roanoke blocks the rook and gets a
queen
and they both have no time the king is
gonna run the king is gonna run rook
takes e5
huge move he's gonna have mate here
where's the mate though
where's the mate there's no mate keep
tracking oh my goodness he pre-moved
king g7 that was unbelievable
yeah that was really nice wow
and ronick wins oh my goodness no but
you have to be upset if you're mid i
think he was up on time there
wrong game wow
that's okay that's oh it's not okay
that's what he's trying to tell him okay
and another oh you can't pre-move that
alexa
what is that what is
come on what is going on this match what
is this match
[Music]
king a5 oh not taking the pawn what's
that about
yeah i don't know whites white's playing
a little bit fast here
doesn't need to be playing that quick
but he is completely winning showing
good technique
yeah oh g2 oh that was so nice wait take
the a pawn take the a-pawn
oh my goodness oh my god
wait it's made that was unbelievable
what how
how did he do that no no no no that's
unacceptable
how does it happen that's unacceptable
want to use your gaming skills in your
career susquehanna international group
is a leading global proprietary trading
firm that uses game theory
and decision science to win in the
financial markets
to learn more about sig visit sig.com
chess
[Music]
okay but there's going to be a rook f7 i
feel like there's got to be some draw
for white but
rook e7 is such a great move oh my gosh
look at this no king moves so the rook
and the ha but look at the time
he's got just so fast
he wins oh my goodness and you see that
heavy breath from danya he wasn't
breathing all game
he takes it on the clock
this might be another win look at the
time taking down yep eight seconds this
is so hard to defend even though these
three puns down and more troubles
at night uh-oh and
oh three takes h6 i'm winning for black
you can move
wow
there we go that's what the people pay
for right there yeah these are your top
two seeds and
that's the end of the game i think eric
one free move ahead of himself
that's gonna be the game one pre
move for for man one bow test gambit for
everyone else
[Laughter]
what just happened there eric oh my gosh
that that is where you are playing so
fast you don't even know what move
you're on
one small pre-move for man one bow tez
gambit and eric just literally didn't
see what hicarum did
[Music]
exactly wow bishop b2 now
you just gotta go i gotta go oh wait
that just loses it you lose the whole
rope probably thought he could get the
exchange back
and that was what i would be six though
oh my gosh but no time four seconds no
this is definitely black's game
should be oh oh terrible
47 was me oh my god
that should have been over oh my
goodness
beautiful check and he's up on time too
gorgeous nice what a game bishop c5
bishop c5 was needed is tang doing oh
oh my gosh oh my god there's mate
there also was mate anybody was queen
yeah what
[Music]
what a finish oh my gosh
that's a tricky defensive move if you
overthink it but here
k2 king a1 even also uh works but
wow what an attacking game bishop f6
only move i think and then rook g6 for
f6
rook she's six for cups sometimes you
just want to take the bigger pictures
and say
i'm going to take all the material also
rook 36 bishop h6
wow what a move and it's me totally sick
by nemo incredible oh my goodness
what a tactic
[Music]
the case of too little too late bishop
e2
and oh my gosh oh no he resigned he
resigned oh
don't resign oh my gosh and he left in
time for one more game
he's trolling what are you doing
vladislav
why would you resign
this should be uh should be over here
bishop d6 yeah
you have to play king g7 there sort of
overlooked that
and now take one c4
oh oh wait no
he resigned but he could have won the
piece oh my god
i've never seen that before oh man
he thought he's gonna take the rook and
he saw the bishop moving he was already
resigned but he would have won the
bishop
[Music]
but this probably is objectively lost
for
black but practically speaking in a time
screen well you can maybe
do you think he's about to uh grab the
a7 pawn at the right moment
yeah we i think a car is waiting for
that he watched that match for sure
yesterday
and but you can't check now that's oh
wait what do the car just do
he moved his rope he's gonna get flagged
here oh
my gosh he tricked him and and oliver's
trying to win on the clock he's trying
to dirty flagging but he might get
flagged he might get flagged
oh the car wins hikaru wins what a game
that was
and we see just the disbelief on
hikaru's face that he
flagged ali razor from that and now they
race that leads further
into the laptop and he is down three
points
takara nakamura
there it is there it is he throws it in
he's up ten
more than ten seconds this is he should
be four oh
oh yeah but should be four at that
moment and now and now he plays it
oh but look at that move throwing in the
check just to gain some time this is
actually
expert bullet oh oh the rocks
already had the match he had the tie but
he lost his rookies losing all of his
pawns
he just has to take the pawn that's it
that's the match that's it hikaru
you can't pre-move there oh he had that
game
and ali raised up for ruja for the
second day
in a row he wins because of this sneaky
little
take something pre-move winning the game
and that is that ali riza farus smiles
he works his way to the finals of the
bullet chess champion
[Music]
you